riot police out in force in central
saint petersburg ahead of nationwide
rallies on sunday
to the supporters of opposition leader
alexey navalny
there was this warning from the russian
the government interior ministry units
and other law enforcement will use
all necessary measures to ensure public
order at sites of mass events
moreover we want that any violent
actions against officers
or refusal to obey their lawful orders
will be prevented
individuals who commit such illegal
actions will be detained
and held accountable according to the
law
the government wants to stop a repeat of
last week's anti-government protests
which took place across at least a
hundred towns and cities
but many of navalny's supporters are
angry after a court ruled this week
that he should be kept in jail until his
next hearing
he's accused of violating the terms of a
previous sentence by traveling to
germany
that's where he was treated for
poisoning and attack he blames on the
russian government
navalny is becoming an increasing
problem for president vladimir putin
he recently released a video of a
seaside mansion which he says belongs to
the russian leader
and was built using illicit funds that's
been denied by a russian billionaire
who's also putin's former judo partner
who says he bought the property two
years ago for almost one billion dollars
either way the video has been viewed
more than a hundred million times
on the one hand uh they've tried to
poison him they failed
so now if they poi if they try to poison
him again at this stage
it's going to produce even more backlash
but if they don't silence him he's also
going to be
coming out with more criticism so
they're sort of stuck between a rock and
a hard place
this week the government crackdown
widened several friends and allies of
novelni including his brother were
arrested
[Music]
anti-kremlin sentiment has rarely been
this public during putin's time
in power and it's likely the rallies on
sunday will be met with even tougher
resistance
victoria gatenbee al jazeera